and i know gabriella was saying in a q a
that you know we can vote with our
dollar in terms of not going to sea
world but then in some sense that might
actually hurt the whales because then
sea world might cut funding that would
be used for something to keep the whales
more comfortable
what can we do i mean hopefully the
message spreads to more than just the
activist community with blackfish that
people can vote with their dollars but
in some sense will that in turn end up
hurting the whales or what can we do to
actually spread this word yeah that's an
it's an interesting question um
i think the reality is that right now
even though they have lots of money
coming in it's not being spent on the
whales anyway so
um i don't see that hitting them uh with
you know at the bottom line of not
buying a ticket and impacting their
sales is is also going to impact what's
happening in terms of the the money
that's used in improving the whale's
lives that is an area i think is very
important that the public put pressure
on sea world to do you have billions of
dollars or millions of dollars coming in
and
some of it needs to be spent
on the whales and it's not happening
right now and seaworld has facilities in
place to do good with their with their
money so i think i i disagree that the
whales are going to suffer any more than
they're already suffering it i think
people by not going to sea world it
really will put pressure on the business
for them to change their business model
and and they can actually make better
lives for the whales and they can be an
educational facility and they can use
their powers for good basically
yes they have a lot of talented people
talented veterinarians and care staff
that um have the power yeah to make some
big change great well thank you both
ladies for being involved in the film
thank you